I want to quickly get the sounds away
before I actually cover integration by
substitution which is why I really
really want to teach you today okay but
it's just a minor term sort of like how
do you explain your answer for this and
in the bookmarks that I've seen that
I've learnt already three or four of
them there's all kinds of different ways
to do it I just want to give you any way
that would be you know first correct
okay so I'm gonna do for Hank will be
with you right now Chloe's symmetrical
areas even though if you read the
question I believe question 4 says in
each of these areas you'll need to
calculate the shaded area by calculating
two areas okay now we're gonna start use
that as a starting point okay
but as you can probably imagine that is
not a very efficient way to do it right
now this shaded region here underneath
these two graphs is what we're trying to
calculate okay the first thing you may
want to watch out for is that I think in
your exercise these two equations I
think this swapped around which might be
confusing so if you got like 128 or
something like that
is that a 16 on three that would explain
why sir Blaine Blaine Cambridge for the
anyway how do we now that I've got them
right way around how would i express
this area in terms of two integrals okay
now let's go from left to right will be
the first one to find this area good sir
I love about moving minus 2 I'm just
going left to right okay and it's going
to end at 0 and as your be closed up
this is where I started okay so far I'm
still under the same function and then
here each changes are not okay
at that point it's here at the origin at
the y-axis I'm no longer calculating the
area under this curve anymore I'm
calculating the area under that swai my
boundary stops
then I'm just sticking this equations
X plus 2 squared and I'm looking for the
area bounded with the x-axis so that's
why I go yes that's the first area
what's the second one
good 0 to 2 of and it's just the other
one so no problems here yeah this is the
way that technical wants you to do it
one bad way it's just inefficient ok
because it's symmetrical right here's
the tricky thing right it's symmetrical
but it's not the kind of symmetry that
we've already been dealing with under
those properties of definite integrals
we looked at before because this is not
an even function it's not even one
function it's two functions right so the
symmetry doesn't come from the fact that
it's even function right so I can't say
on the next line it's equal to something
something something as it's an even
function because these aren't even
functions and so what am I going to do
well I'm gonna still write down the same
thing it's a double of a particular area
and I can choose either side right which
side do you think you would choose
probably the one without the negatives
in it okay I mean mathematical it's
gonna be the same but this is just gonna
have a double negative in it that's all
okay so I'm gonna double with this area
here okay but I can't just go from two
integrals which are completely different
and then say well I'm gonna choose to
double one of them I have to explain I
have to justify why I'm taking this one
and activating it twice okay now what is
the reason
well it's about symmetry right so I'm
going to say by symmetry okay but this
is not enough I need to explain what
kind of symmetry it is right and when we
do 4b you'll see why this is so
important this area right the one that
I've worked out where is the axis of
symmetry for the area it's it's the y
axis in this case right so the way I
would say that news is about what's the
equation of my axis it's x equals zero
okay so this is a critical wine it's
what allows you to justify making them
that's so much nicer and easier okay so
that's kind of the apart that I was
looking for really it'll save you from
you know people say going from this line
this line that we talk about what okay
this is the one now you can just go
ahead what's this this is X minus 2
cubed divided by 3 evaluate the limits
and off you go
I think you guys are fine from there I
think for a memory you'll get 16 or 3 I
think yes right that's exactly the right
question right what is it that you know
I've got plus 2 here and minus here
why is it just sort of what happened to
this guy and the answer is I could
choose because it's symmetrical I can
choose whichever one so I'm just gonna
choose the one that's convenient to me
namely where I don't have negative it
that's all right question you may not
have not write down this line okay now
probably yes would I do it because again
what am i after right I'm after as a
Monica looking to see if this student
can demonstrate understanding of what
the question is about okay
now could you jump to here if you had a
good diagram yeah okay but this isn't
actually the area I'm trying to work out
this is the real area it's wrong - - -
and it's this function in this domain
and so on okay
so I think this is a safe way to go
about it could you if you're in a hurry
could you chop that off probably okay
but at least in my sake I'm going to
write it down that'll sort of saved me
from making errors later on what if I
wrote this down first but I got wrong
like I got this equation or something
like that and I've got no way to go back
and check if I okay so okay now let's
quickly look at the next
and I thought you didn't bring my own
let's look at full babe okay now by the
way to say well to say by symmetry it's
vitally important you actually have a
diagram there okay because otherwise
it's like well where is the symmetry
right it's a little bit like saying from
the graph which is why I've drawn my
today you've got your question there
okay let's have a look at the next one
right yeah again I'm going to write the
area first in terms of the two equations
the to actual residuals okay so I think
the first one they provided the point of
intersection right so starts at the
origin it goes up to three on two right
and that's just right your second area
it takes over three over two and then it
goes all the way until three
okay what's the equation it's like X
minus three I think such a gap yeah okay
now again I get to choose which of these
intervals I'm gonna which is area I'm
going to double so obviously in this
case the one you would choose is the
first one right number one has got less
terms and number two because zero in its
they'll be nice and easy to evaluate so
I'm gonna do this and then begin include
this right now it's not symmetry about
this anymore it's completely different
right it's been moved over if these
shift that's right so I have to say by
symmetry about and then name the axis
okay
so vitally important that's nephew
sometimes we don't actually have to you
have to calculate that because they
weren't just provide you the point
and so on okay so please make sure you
include that line it's really important